Transcription: Melissa Munns
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
J’ai quelque chose
d’assez étonnant à vous dire,
c’est que tous dans cette salle,
sans exception,
nous avons tous entendu
le même premier son.
Ce premier son, c’était celui-là :
(Battements cardiaques)
C’est le son du cœur de votre maman.
Entre la 26ᵉ et 28ᵉ semaine
se crée l’audition fœtale.
Avant de sentir, avant de voir,
vous avez entendu.
C’est ce qui explique sûrement
que le son et la musique soient attachés
au plus profond de votre âme.
Gaïa, notre mère à tous,
la Terre, est née
il y a 4,5 milliards d’années.
On ne va pas se mentir,
on n’était pas là au début,
on est arrivé vers la saison six ou sept.
On est arrivé à peu près
il y a 100 000 ans : on écoutait la Terre,
le moindre bruissement, comme ça,
le petit animal furtif, on l’écoutait.
Et puis, chemin faisant, on a commencé
à moins écouter la Terre.
Puis maintenant, on l'écoute plus du tout.
D’ailleurs, maintenant,
la Terre fait ce bruit là :
(Klaxon et vrombissement des voitures
dans un embouteillage)
Se pose une question :
Et si on roulait mieux ?
Et si on roulait moins ?
Et si on s’écoutait un peu plus ?
Et si on levait la tête
de nos téléphones ?
Qu’est-ce qu’il se passerait ?
(Chants d’oiseaux)
Une étude américaine a prouvé que
des groupes d’humains,
quand ils étaient exposés
à des sons de la Nature,
avaient une progression de 184%
de leur santé générale.
184 % !
Et 28% de baisse
du stress et de l’angoisse.
Vous imaginez ?
Donc ce que je vous propose,
plutôt que de prendre un antidépresseur
ou un cours de yoga,
pendant les prochaines 20 minutes,
nous allons écouter la Terre.
Vous êtes prêts ?
Très bien, revenons d’abord en arrière.
(Bruit de rembobinage)
On parle souvent des peintures rupestres,
mais on parle peu de l’endroit
où étaient dessinées
ces peintures rupestres.
Les archéologues se sont rendus compte que
ces peintures rupestres étaient dessinées
exactement à l’endroit où la voix
allait porter le plus dans la caverne.
C’est incroyable !
Ça veut dire que les hommes
préhistoriques, les hommes de Néandertal,
avaient déjà pleinement conscience
de la puissance du son.
Je trouve qu’on est
dans une assez jolie grotte.
Est-ce que ça vous dit de tester
l’acoustique de celle-là ?
Je vais compter jusqu’à trois
et vous allez me faire un cri
d’hommes et de femmes de Néandertal.
Vous êtes prêts ? Un, deux, trois !
(cris)
Non, ça c’est un cri de fans
de Patrick Bruel, ça n’a rien à voir.
Non, on va le refaire,
Néandertal, qui vient de là.
Un, deux, trois
(Cris plus fort)
L’acoustique est bonne
mais vous me faites peur.
Alors Henri de Régnier a dit :
« La musique est faite des bruits
de la Nature et des soupirs de l’âme. »
C'est joli.
On a entendu des oiseaux au tout début.
Les compositeurs,
depuis la nuit des temps,
se sont inspirés du monde animal.
Je pense qu’on a tous entendu, petits,
Prokofiev avec Pierre et le Loup.
Vous savez avec cette flûte traversière
(son de flute)
qui imite l’oiseau.
Mais beaucoup plus tôt,
Clément Janequin, avec ses polyphonies,
a essayé de reproduire
la basse-cour au XVᵉ siècle.
(chants saccadés)
Je fais hyper bien le coq.
XVᵉ siècle ! Incroyable !
Plus récemment, le compositeur Chassol
a décidé de prendre
une mélodie d’oiseau et de la doubler
au synthétiseur, écoutez :
(musique)
Ça marche bien.
Alors...
Le monde animal a inspiré
les compositeurs mais également la Nature.
En 1742, Jean-Sébastien Bach reçoit
une demande du comte de Keyzerling,
qui était mélomane et hélas, insomniaque.
Il lui envoie un petit papier :
« Dis donc mon Jean-Seb - Jean-Seb Bach -
Dis donc mon Jean-Seb,
comme je dors pas la nuit,
tu veux pas m’écrire
une petite musique de nuit ? »
Oui, musique de nuit, c’est Mozart,
c’est pas Bach, mais Bach écrit
pour le comte de Keyserling
une musique pour tenter de l’apaiser
pour trouver le sommeil.
Ce sera les Variations Goldberg.
Un chef d'œuvre absolu.
En 1981, Glenn Gould enregistre
les Variations Goldberg.
Je vous propose de vérifier les vertus
apaisantes de cette musique.
Vous allez prendre une grande inspiration,
vous soufflez tout doucement,
vous allez fermer les yeux.
Écoutons l’aria de ces variations.
(musique)
Est-ce que ça fonctionne ?
Est-ce que vous avez senti comme ça,
une onde radieuse ?
Vous savez pourquoi ça fonctionne ?
Parce qu’en fait, cette interprétation
de Glenn Gould de 1981
est calée sur le ressac des vagues.
(Bruit des vagues)
(Musique)
La Nature, quand on l’écoute, nous apaise.
Est-ce que vous savez
qu’on peut sauver du corail
en faisant écouter à des poissons
le son du corail ?
Là j’en ai perdu deux ou trois,
j’ai l’impression.
Je vais vous expliquer.
Imaginez que le corail en bonne santé
émet un son, des petits craquements
que les poissons entendent et viennent
créer un écosystème autour du corail.
Hélas, le corail en train
de mourir n’émet plus ce son.
Et donc ces poissons s’en vont et
donc ça accélère la mort des coraux.
Des océonologues ont eu l’idée géniale
de tremper des enceintes, comme ça,
à côté du corail en train de mourir
et de diffuser le son
de corail en bonne santé.
(bruits aquatiques)
Les poissons sont revenus
et ont donné une deuxième vie au corail.
Incroyable !
On peut écouter la Terre,
mais on peut écouter la mer aussi.
Vous savez certainement
avant une catastrophe,
que ce soit un tsunami
ou un tremblement de terre,
généralement, il n’y a plus de bruit :
les oiseaux, s’en vont.
Même les bancs de poissons
quittent les rives.
Les éléphants se déplacent aussi,
ils se parlent par infrasons, d’ailleurs.
On a fait un test récemment,
c'est incroyable.
Et alors, l’université de Washington
a réussi à enregistrer et à transformer
un son qui est inaudible pour nous
mais pas pour les animaux,
qui est ce tremblement harmonique,
juste avant une éruption.
Ils ont appelé ça le cri du volcan,
c’est criant de vérité.
(bruit sourd)
Et juste après l'éruption.
On a perdu tout ça.
On en entend plus.
Pourtant, on a dû l'entendre
à un moment dans notre vie.
Parfois la Terre nous parle,
mais on ne comprend pas
ce qu’elle nous dit.
Comme par exemple avec ceci :
(bruit)
On dirait Chewbacca
qui se réveille le matin.
(bruit)
Vous savez ce que c’est en fait?
Ce sont le chant des dunes.
(bruit)
Ce sont des dunes de sable.
Il y en a une trentaine
dans le monde, répertoriées.
Quand vous avez des déplacements,
des petites avalanches
ou changements thermiques,
le sable qui se déplace crée
une fondamentale, une harmonique,
et crée cette sonorité
qui va jusqu’à 110 décibels.
C'est le bruit d'un TGV qui passe.
C’est incroyable !
Continuant dans la thématique Star Wars.
(bruits)
On a l’impression qu’on est
dans le Faucon Millenium
et qu’il y a une attaque
de l’Étoile noire, pas du tout,
c’est le lac Tenaya
dans le parc Yosemite, un lac gelé.
Et en fait le son qu’on entend là,
c’est le lac au réveil,
quand le soleil se lève,
la glace se fendille
et ça fait ce son.
C’est incroyable.
(bruit)
On était dans l’espace, avec Star Wars,
je vous propose
de prendre un peu de hauteur
et d’aller écouter la Terre
d’un peu plus loin.
(Espace, frontière de l’infini vers
laquelle voyage notre vaisseau spatial.
Sa mission de cinq ans...)
Ça ne va pas durer cinq ans,
je vous rassure.
Là, je vais avoir besoin de beaucoup
de calme et beaucoup de concentration
puisque nous allons écouter
le son de l'espace.
Aucun bruit, écoutez bien.
En fait, il n’y a pas
de son dans l’espace
parce que les ondes sonores ont
besoin de matière pour se propager.
Pas d'oxygène, pas de matière,
pas d'ondes.
Blaise Pascal a dit : « C’est le silence
éternel des espaces infinis. »
J’adore ! Le silence éternel
des espaces infinis.
Beaucoup plus tôt, Pythagore,
- Pythagore qui était mathématicien
et astronome - a créé un concept.
Il a appelé ça l’harmonie des sphères.
L’harmonie des sphères pour lui,
c’était ce concept :
il imaginait que les planètes
étaient des sphères,
qu’elles tournaient sur elles-mêmes
et fabriquaient un son incroyable,
qu’il imaginait dans sa tête,
l’harmonie des sphères.
Comme il y avait sept sphères,
il connaissait sept planètes à l’époque,
il a imaginé, en fonction de leur taille,
de leur diamètre et de leur distance,
sept notes.
C’est d’ailleurs pour ça que dans la gamme
de la musique occidentale, nous avons…
(gamme au piano)
sept notes - on le doit à Pythagore
qui avait sept planètes à l’époque.
Depuis que je suis enfant, que je connais
cette histoire, ça me fascine.
Je me dis, mais qu’est-ce qu’il avait en
tête, comme son Pythagore à l’époque ?
Qu’est-ce qu’il imaginait pour
cette harmonie des sphères ?
La première idée qui me vient
à chaque fois,
quand vous avez un verre de cristal,
vous trempez votre doigt
et le glissez dessus.
Vous avez ce son en tête ?
On dirait un verrophone
ou un cristal Baschet.
Eh bien, j’ai eu l’idée de recréer
cette harmonie des sphères
avec les sept planètes.
On va faire le voyage en même temps.
Vous allez fermer les yeux et on va partir
à la rencontre de l’harmonie des sphères.
Allons y.
(bruit mélodieux)
Vous avez voyagé ?
Il était fort, mon Pitou.
C'est le surnom de Pythagore.
Je vous ai un tout petit peu menti,
en fait.
Récemment, des Américains, à nouveau,
je crois que l’Université de Washington,
a réussi à transformer les ondes
électromagnétiques d’une planète
pour les transformer en sons.
Donc on peut écouter une planète.
Je vous propose de découvrir
Uranus par exemple.
Uranus.
Maintenant on va écouter
les anneaux de Saturne.
On va écouter la Terre de très loin.
Les planètes et l’espace ont toujours
captivé les compositeurs,
toujours, depuis tout temps.
En 1918, vous avez Gustave Holst
qui a écrit un poème symphonique
qui s’appelle Les Planètes, justement.
Sept thèmes sur les sept planètes.
Je vous propose d’écouter Mars,
Mars la guerrière, Gustav Holst :
(Musique)
Si jamais vous n’avez jamais
écouté Gustave Holst,
vous pouvez peut être avoir déjà entendu
ce morceau dans Star Wars
avec l’attaque des Stormtroopers.
(Musique)
Oops!
On a écouté le ciel, on a écouté l’espace,
on a écouté la Terre, l’eau, les oiseaux.
Moi, j’ai envie de vous écouter,
vous, maintenant.
J'ai envie de savoir si vous êtes capable
d'écouter et d'échanger avec la Terre.
Je vous propose de parler
le même langage que la Terre.
Parlons le langage des éléments.
On va essayer de faire de la pluie,
du vent, peut-être même des grillons.
Vous êtes prêts à jouer ou pas ?
Public : Oui !
À part devant,
les mauvais élèves de d’habitude,
vous êtes prêts à jouer ?
Public : Oui !
C’est mieux ! Alors, je vous explique,
c’est très simple.
De là à de là, vous allez
faire la petite pluie.
Vous prenez votre main et avec le doigt,
vous tapez dedans de façon aléatoire.
Allez y.
(bruit de pluie)
De là à de là, les mauvais élèves.
je connais...
C’est bon, je vous fais signe après,
eux, ils sont chauds !
Les bons élèves,
ils partent tout de suite.
« Oui, il nous a dit, on l’a fait.
On est rentré chez nous, comme ça. »
Je vous ferai signe.
Les moins bons élèves.
Vous allez faire ça pas trop fort.
Vous, c’est la pluie
sur les toits comme ça :
Pas trop fort.
(bruit de pluie)
Enfin un peu plus fort quand même.
Voilà , hop, on arrête!
Quand je vous le dirai, c’est pa
très Covid mais vous avez des masques,
vous soufflerez pour faire le vent,
on y va : petite pluie !
(bruit de pluie)
(coup de tonnerre)
Un peu de vent, un peu de vent.
(bruit de vent)
Monsieur, vous faites une mouette ?
(cri)
Petite mouette, mais très bien.
C’est splendide !
C’est génial !
Vous le faites très bien.
Hop, on n’arrête, plus de pluie,
vous savez ce qu’on fait maintenant ?
Un tout petit peu de vent
et on va faire des grillons.
Prenez vos mains et faites comme ça.
(bruit de frottement)
Un peu de vent.
(bruit de vent)
C’est parfait.
Je pense que la Terre vous écoute.
Merci beaucoup.
Je vous propose une dernière
expérience sonore, tous ensemble.
On va aller du plus haut au plus petit,
du haut au centre.
On va partir de la plus haute cime.
Prenons par exemple le mont Blanc :
on va partir tout en haut du mont Blanc.
On va descendre comme ça le long,
le long des coteaux, très, très vite.
On va arriver dans une forêt.
On va traverser les arbres,
entendre des oiseaux.
Puis on va rentrer dans l’océan.
On va entendre une baleine,
puis on va descendre tout au fond
de l’océan, près de la croûte terrestre.
On va traverser la croûte terrestre
aller tout au fond, au cœur,
là ou se crée le magma.
Et on va peut être découvrir ensemble
le secret du centre de la Terre.
(bruits)
On a commencé ce voyage en écoutant
le cœur de votre maman.
Et on le termine en écoutant le cœur
de Gaïa, Alma mater, notre mère à tous.
Écoutons-là, prenons soin d’elle.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)